Rob Rob America on Tik Tok. You're on
stage. You disagree?
>> I do disagree, man. What's going on,
gentlemen?
>> What's up, man? What's up?
>> Yeah.
>> Hey, what's going on, man? So, so
there's a couple of of situation or
verses. Um, one being God sent his only
begotten son. That's two different
people or two different entities right
there in itself.
>> Two different persons. Amen. That's what
we believe.
>> Yeah. I'm I'm And what I do, I believe
in the conversation. And I believe in
steel, sharpening steel. So yeah, I make
a point. You guys rebuttal.
>> Well, we we believe that. We're in
agree. It's not that two different
persons there.
>> All right. So that that is one that
would say that would lead me to say
they're not the same person.
>> We we believe that. We we believe God is
multi-personal.
>> So you believe that they are the same
but different at the same time.
>> So they're the same in one way. They're
the same in their essence, but they're
different in their personhood.
>> They're different in their personhood.
Like when it says in Hebrews 1:3 that
the son is the image of the personhood
of the father because they're different
persons.
>> Okay. So what about when it says that
Jesus was given the power of God?
>> Well, it doesn't say he's given the
power. Um it just says he was given
authority and that's just
>> given the authority. How can he give
himself if they're the same person?
>> Bro, we literally just said we don't
believe the same person. We're they're
different persons.
>> Okay. So you're saying that Jesus is not
God then? No,
>> bro. We're saying God is more than one
person. There are three persons that are
God because they have the same essence.
It's why they're the same God. It's one
God, three persons.
>> Okay. The Bible refers to Jesus as the
word being made flesh. Okay.
>> Mhm.
>> So that is still a different entity. How
are all three the same? That's my
question.
>> They're the same in their essence.
They're the same in their essence.
They're different in their personhood.
So if me and you were were and not
trying to be blasphemy, if we were in
that position, how would our
>> you blasphemous creature,
>> how would how would what would our
essence be? Our soul.
>> You talking about right now?
>> Yeah. Like like Yeah. So you're saying
>> our essence would be our human nature
right now.
>> Jeremy, our essence would be our human
nature right now.
>> Okay. We're in our human nature right
now. Okay. Are you asking me what is our
human nature?
>> No. You just asked me what would our
nature be? I said it's the human nature.
It's the human nature. Okay. So, what
would our essence be?
>> Essence and nature is the same thing.
>> So, all three of their nature, the
father, the son, the holy spirit, their
nature is the same.
>> Yes.
>> Their nature is the same.
>> Yeah. Because it says right that the
fullness of deity or the fullness of the
nature dwelt in Christ bodily. It's the
same nature of the father. That same
deity that the father is
>> one mind. They one mind they move as
one.
>> You got a you got a trinitarian in the
car with you? That's how he spitting
back there.
>> I'm not I'm not Trinitarian.
>> Well, what you just said sounded very
trinitarian. I ain't gonna lie.
>> Yeah. They of one mind, you know, they
move as one.
>> Yeah.
>> Sound good to me, bro.
>> I'm Israelite. I'm not a trinitarian.
>> You're Israelite.
>> Yeah.
>> You You You think salvation only goes to
Israel or you believe Gentiles could be
saved, too?
>> I'm not.
>> They have They have different forms of
every religion. Christianity has
thousands. Islam has hundreds. So, when
they say Israelite, you know what I
mean? It's like different forms of them.
I believe salvation is for all people.
>> Okay.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely.
>> Okay. Good.
>> Order, but there's order in heaven.
>> That's what I'm saying. They saying that
Jesus is God.
>> And I'm like, he he was granted that
power.
>> What? You could be granted the ability
to be God,
>> man. He was given he was given that
authority,
>> bro. That's like saying you didn't go.
>> Wait. You you could be you could be
given the authority to be the most high
God
>> when you are when you are special. I
don't know whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa.
>> Look Jesus born without a mother without
a father.
>> Just really quick just really quick.
This what this what the Bible says. The
Bible says in Isaiah 40
>> um
>> I think it's 46. I don't forgive me but
it's in it's in one of those 40s where
he says that I give my glory to no
other. Right? You guys, you guys know
the verse, right?
>> Okay.
>> So, there's no way that somebody can be
elevated to the status of the most high
God and not actually truly be the most
high God
>> cuz he shares his glory with no other.
That would be now blasphemous and now be
a a second god that he's created. That
would be silly.
>> That would be blasphemous.
>> Okay.
>> So, if Jesus has the authority of the
most high God, then that means he is the
most high God. He He can't be anything
else.
>> So while he's God and so you're going to
rever revert back to the the essence.
What is God doing while Jesus is God?
>> What's the father what's the father
doing? You mean
>> yeah sitting on the throne like you know
>> the father the father sits on the throne
and orchestrates the plan. The son goes
out and then carries out the plan and
then the spirit executes the plan.
>> Understood. Understood. Spirit executes.
I can see that. Yeah, but the Holy
Spirit was never said to be like God.
>> 2 Samuel 23:es 2 to 2 to 4, man.
>> 2 Samuel vers 23. Watch what it says.
I'll put on the screen so we can look
>> human encyclopedia right there.
>> 2 Samuel 23. Let's look at this real
quick, man. Let's Hey, this Bible, man.
What's the only thing we do around here?
>> Hold up. Hold up. Look, I'm trying to
get my full thought in saying things.
That's why I didn't say it all the way
through. You know what I'm saying?
>> It's all good. But what I'm saying is
the Holy Spirit was never to be
worshiped as as as even Christ was
pray to the Holy Spirit. But we only
worship the father. Christ.
>> Oh, that's a good point.
>> Is all all it goes to the father.
>> Would you guys would you guys agree?
Would you guys agree that prayer is
worship
>> in Jesus name?
>> Would you guys pray? Prayer is
communication.
Communication with who?
>> With the most high. Okay.
>> You pray to the Holy Spirit. You praying
to the most high. Yeah.
>> Let me ask a question that I learned
from my church. When you translate Jesus
into Hebrew, what do you get,
>> bro? That's something else.
>> You got to give me
>> fellas fellas fellas fellas fellas
fellas fellas. We got to focus.
>> I know, but that's that that question is
way off topic. We can get to that next.
>> Let's focus on the topic. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on.
>> I'm about to show you guys in the
scripture where one explicitly the
spirit of Yahweh is identified as Yahweh
himself. Okay, that the spirit, the Holy
Spirit of God is called God. Okay, so
let me show you guys this real quick
right quick. Let me just show you all
this real quick, man. All right, can
y'all see the verses on the screen?
>> Wait, just before you read, I'm going
just show you the reference. This is 2
Samuel 23:es 2 to 3. Okay, this is David
speaking. All right, so watch what David
says. He says, "The spirit of the Lord
speaks by me." So who's talking? The
spirit is talking.
>> Okay,
>> right through David. And he says, "His
word, the spirit's word is on my tongue.
The God of Israel has spoken. The rock
of Israel has said to me." So the spirit
is identified as the God of Israel and
the rock of Israel.
>> Okay. Let's put it in the King James
version, please.
>> Okay.
>> Not a biggie, but I just want to make
sure all
>> to me makes sense to me.
>> All right.
>> They was in standard right there.
>> Yeah. which I don't believe they all the
time be different, but just for my
reading.
>> Got it right here.
>> The spirit of the the spirit of the Lord
spake by me and his word is was on my
tongue. The God of Israel said the rock
of Israel spake to me. Right? He that
ruleth over men uh ruleth over men must
be just ruling in the fear of God. So
same thing, the spirit of the Lord is
identified as the God of Israel and the
rock of Israel, the one who's speaking
to David.
>> Okay. Okay. What about Jesus when he's
saying
>> more Christ that he was saying Christ?
>> Okay. What about Jesus saying you cannot
get to the father but by me?
>> That's another example, brother. That's
another example.
>> That's still him putting the father
above him.
>> No, that's not him putting the father.
How is that putting the father? So is it
is it is it is he is he putting himself
above the father then when he says that
no one comes to me unless the father
draws him and puts himself as the
destination that the father's bringing
people to Jesus
>> but that's why I don't believe in hell
right there but
>> forget that's focus
preacher to that
>> because it's like that's cruel you were
talking to some other brother earlier
about cruelty but
>> yeah topic
>> they focus so when so when Jesus says
that it's the that the father draws men
to him
>> that Jesus is the destination and the
father is the one who brings them
>> does that mean that the that Jesus is
above the father
>> no
>> so similarly just because Jesus brings
people to to the father doesn't mean
that the father is greater in nature or
onlogically than the son they it's it
it's a mutual glor the son glorifies the
father and the father glorifies the son
it's a mutual glorification bro
>> cuz they won
>> they
There you go.
>> There you go. That's the trinity. That's
the trinity. They are one.
>> But the oneness of the relationship
between God and man is no different than
we were wanted between God I mean man
and woman. You know what I'm saying?
>> There is a there is a difference but
there there is a a similarity in the
unity. Yeah. Just just how the just how
the the Bible says that man and wife
become one flesh. They join together one
and it's a compound unity.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Because because because a woman
has to submit to the man just as the man
that's why we're always referred to as
the brides of Christ.
>> You know what I'm saying? Because of our
>> So, right. So, do you guys see how and
and and notice even though your wife
submits to you, that doesn't mean that
she's any less human than you are.
Right.
>> Right.
>> Right. So, you guys are still equal in
nature because you're both human. You
have that same human value. The same way
even though Jesus humbles himself and
submits to the father doesn't mean that
he's any less most high any less God
than the father is they have the same
nature. Jesus Jesus just takes the
humble role.
>> Okay?
>> I mean because he he had the mortal part
of it.
>> He took he took on flesh. That's what
Philippians says. Even though he existed
in the form of God, he did not count
equality with God. Talking about the
father something he had to hold on to.
We didn't have to hold on to that. But
it says he made himself of no
reputation, humbling himself by taking
the form of a servant, being born in the
likeness of men. That's literally that's
Bible, bro.
>> I love it, bro. That's scripture right
there, bro. Listen, I'm on a journey to
learn who my father is, bro. That's why
I'm like, you know, I I I know you was
canceling people out, but I He said,
"Ask what you will of me." And these are
questions that I had, man. He also said,
"Still sharpen steel." Yeah.
>> But I saw you on here. I seen some of
your videos and and I and I definitely
appreciate the the platform. Somebody on
here has those same questions.
>> Yep.
>> And that's all we doing. Spreading
season. I love
>> And not notice the difference between
you and your brother versus some of our
other previous guests. You guys were
humble about your disagreements and able
to reason with the scripture. The other
guys were arrogant and just arguing for
argument's sake, not being honest and
humble about their disagreement, you
know? So, that's completely different.
This was a very wholesome
>> dialogue that we're having with you
guys. I I love it, man. I appreciate it.
I could do this for hours.
>> When you when you when you're presenting
us a if we're in a class and we're
presenting things to a person teaching
them, we would reference where we would
got the things that we know. that makes
a strong foundation of what you're
trying to say. So when you
>> build your case around the Bible, it's
hard to dispute what you have to say.
Exactly.
>> Because it's called the word. You know
what I'm saying? And there's nothing
more solid than the word of God, what it
says.
>> You can't change what it says. So,
>> you know, there's things that people do
and live and when you point them out in
the Bible, it says, "Hey, this is what
this says right here." Yeah.
>> You know what I'm saying? If you part of
this group, if you say you one with God,
you can't dispute his word.
>> Exactly.
So that yeah, you guys are y'all are on
the right track, man. Y'all keep
studying, bro. Keep studying. Keep
listening to these videos, these live
streams, cuz as you see, I we like to go
Bible, man. We like to give it Bible.
Everything that I'm going to say is
going to be there's going to be a verse
that's saying what I'm saying. Now, I
don't got to manipulate nothing. I ain't
got to twist nothing. It's going to be
in the verse. You get what I'm saying?
>> And I read myself. Anything that you
tell me, any any videos that I might
have seen, I definitely shot to the
Bible immediately for myself. So yeah, I
believe the study and showed thou self
approved is real.
>> Exactly. Exactly. I I appreciate y'all
coming up, man. Keep watching. Keep
studying. And if y'all got uh on the
next time I do a topic like this, y'all
got more questions, come on through,
>> man. Absolutely, man. God bless, man.
>> God bless you, dude.
>> All right, bro. Take care, man.
>> Peace.
>> See guys, that's how to have a real
conversation, man.
>> You can disagree, but be humble about
your disagreement. Be humble about your
position. And if you're really about
truth, you're going to you're going to
go with the truth. You're going to go
with Bible if you guys say you love the
Bible just like these brothers did.
Great example of that, man.
>> He be doing apologetics and
>> Uh, see, I got to go to Okay, there we
go. All right.
>> Okay. Going doing pretty doing this is
interesting, man. First time doing the
stream like this and it's pretty solid.
I
>> I like it like this a little bit better.
I think it's a little bit easier.
Probably a little bit easier on you,
too. So,
>> it's way easier cuz we don't got to keep
switching.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I don't have to like be on
the live myself either. I'll mute here
and unmute here. That's a little bit
better.
>> Yeah. All right, let's bring up our next
guest. Uh, Sword X. Sword X sound like
he got some He going to do some work.
What's up, man?
>> Yo, be down. I'm looking. I'm looking.
Well, well, Jesus got his shoe. No.
>> Do you disagree?
>> I don't have, bro.
>> What's your religion?
>> So, I'm secular Muslim.
>> Secular Muslim.
>> I mean, yeah. What does that mean?
>> Secular. So, uh, there is mistakes.
there is errors or mistakes in in the
Quran.
>> Okay.
>> Some traditions, but I believe a portion
of it is true and good because I I mean
I'm I'm in Iraq. I live in Iraq and my
>> You got to be careful.
>> Yeah. My whole life. No, no, I'm not
saying there's a lot of uh atheist
around here.
>> Oh, really?
>> You can just say, "Yeah, there's a lot
of atheist and not religious ones, too.
It's crazy."
>> So, you believe in some parts of the
Quran. You don't believe that it's all
from God, but you believe some parts of
it is. And
>> no, I think it's inspired. A lot of
portion of it is inspired. Not a divine
revelation.
>> Okay.
>> No religion has a divi divine
revelation. It's all inspired. I think
of it. Some large portion of it of any
religion like so.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> So, so why do you disagree that Jesus is
God and the trinity is true?
>> Yeah. So I'm going to keep it about a
simple theology, a simple logic out of
religion, out of uh
the religions. I mean generally out of
them just a simple logic and theology.
Jesus Jesus cannot be a god because the
uncreated cannot cannot be created.
>> That's why that's why Jesus is God cuz
he's uncreated
>> and he's a human, bro.
>> Where do you get it from that he's
created though?
>> He's a man. Yeah, but you realize he
even says that he existed before he took
on my flesh, though.
>> Well, yeah, I disagree with him.
>> Why? Why do you disagree with that?
>> Because God cannot be created.
>> We're saying he's not created. We're
saying he existed eternally before
>> he's a man.
>> But we're saying he existed eternally
before he became man. We're asking why
do you disagree with that? That he
existed eternally before he became man.
>> He existed before he came became a man.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. He has to divide providing
evidence for that. What does that mean?
>> Yeah, sure. So, uh the Bible says that
Jesus is the one who is the word of God
who through whom all things were
created. Okay. This is John chapter This
is John chapter 1. This is the gospel.
John chapter one.
>> John chapter Let me pull this up.
>> Sure.
>> John chapter one. No, I'll show it on
the screen for you. You don't even got
to do all that work.
>> Yeah, it's fine.
>> Yep. I'll show it on the screen for you,
big dog. Just one second. All right. So,
here it is right here on the left. This
is John chapter 1. It says, "In the
beginning was the word
>> and the word was with God and the word
was God."
>> Yeah, that's a wrong wording here.
>> No, that's perfect word. I I couldn't
word it any better than this.
>> No, because you say the God is the word,
right?
>> That's right. That's what he says.
>> In the beginning was the word and the
word was with God. So, God was in the
possession of God.
>> That's right. So you have you have God
who exists as three persons.
>> You have the father, God the father,
God.
>> You have his word who is also God and
you have the spirit as well. So you have
three persons who are identified as God.
You see two of them here. You see God
who is the father and then God who is
the word.
>> Yeah. But I'm saying the word is the
posession is the possession of God.
Possession.
>> The word is God. As it says the word was
God and the word was God. Yeah. That's
that's the wrong wording. It says,
>> well, according to at least at least
let's do this. Can we at least be honest
>> that according to the text it says that
the word is God? Like so the word is
God, right?
>> That's why I'm saying it's changed. It's
not super.
>> Can you show Can you show us a change?
Like do you have a manuscript of John
1:1 that doesn't say this?
>> No. So that
>> the the doctrine was I'm confused.
>> It was supposed to read it like that.
This has been this has been the text and
this has been the doctrine for over
2,000 years. What are what are you
saying has been changed? What I'm saying
is a it's changed because it's a a
contradiction itself.
>> How well was well that that it's not a
change then. You're just saying it
contradicts itself. So what's the
contradiction?
>> Because God cannot be with God.
>> Why not?
>> Because the the word it says the word is
with God.
>> Yeah. Why can't God be with God?
>> So how the hell can
>> Yeah. The question is why can't God be
more than one person? So that one person
is with another person that's also God.
>> Yeah. That's Yeah. One God with one Yes.
Well, one God is one person only. Cannot
be multiple persons.
>> Says why?
>> Why? Because it's illogical. You can't
share.
>> What's illogical about it?
>> Yeah. What's illogical?
>> Well, first the the essence the essence
of God. It cannot be shared with the
created beings because God is uncreated.
>> Bro, we believe that Jesus is uncreated.
We're asking what is the issue with God?
contradiction with God being multiple
persons.
>> Yeah. And I'm telling you that Jesus is
created. He's not God.
>> No, we don't believe Jesus is created.
>> I know you don't believe.
>> There's nowhere in the Bible you'll find
where it says Jesus is a created person.
>> That's why I'm I'm keeping it. That's
why I said I'm keeping it out of
religion. Just simple logic.
>> Bro, what simple logic? How how does
simple logic tell us whether or not
Jesus is a created person or not?
>> Because of this logic that he created
uncreated. Can God wait? Can God take on
flesh?
>> No.
>> Logically, why not?
>> No. Because it will be bound to his
systems of creation. Because he will be
bound
>> bound to bound to what?
>> Bound on his creation. On his creation.
>> So, so God can't take on So, wait. So,
God can't take on flesh and then
expanding the universe.
>> God cannot be take flesh because he will
be his creation.
>> No, no, no. Why can't he take on flesh
though and still retain and still retain
his properties of being God? That's what
I'm telling. It's a contradiction.
>> What is the contradiction?
>> The contradiction is that God is not
created. Being a human being is
>> Well, you say the word uh
>> I mean, we not going nowhere and be
honest, bro.
>> How are we not going anywhere,
>> bro? You just keep saying it's a
contradiction, but you're not giving me
the contradiction like what is the
actual contradiction with saying God can
take on flesh but still retain his
properties of being omnipresent?
>> No, I didn't say that God can't take
flesh. That's literally what you said.
>> Do we need to replay it?
>> You literally said no. God cannot take
flight. Should I replay it? Should I
replay the stream?
>> He's gone, bro. Uh,
>> like, what are we doing?
>> Con Logic, how you doing? Conlogic,
you're on stage. Con Logic going once.
Okay, he's gone. Okay. Uh, Mark Suave,
you're on stage.
>> Hello.
>> How you doing? You uh what's your what's
your religion?
>> The I am atheist and I
>> What brought you What brought you to
this stream? Because there's literally
no good reason to be Christian.
>> That's not the topic of the stream.
>> What?
>> Okay. What's the Okay. Well, I I I mean,
I disagree with the stream anyways.
>> What do you disagree with?
>> Okay. So, you disagree being God.
>> Why do you disagree with that?
>> Uh because God does not exist.
>> Okay. What's your evidence for that?
>> Uh
what
>> what's your evidence? You said God. You
made a positive claim.
>> He's trolling, man. Get out of here. He
He just left his own. I didn't even kick
him. He left on his own.
>> That's crazy. I don't I don't want to
mess up your name, but uh ending with B.
You're on stage. Your first name starts
with a T and then you got B in your
name. Something like to to
>> sound like his mic is messed up.
>> Yeah, I had to mute him. All right,
let's see here. Sam Hayyatt, how you
doing? Sam Hayyatt, you're on stage.
>> I'm doing great. Thank you for asking,
brother.
>> Awesome. You disagree with the title?
>> Well, I do have a problem with the
Trinity. Otherwise, I'm all good.
>> Sure.
>> All right. What's what's wrong with the
trinity?
>> Yeah. Uh since like you know see I don't
find this word trinity and uh then holy
spirit is god that is not found. And
then like you know believing that holy
spirit and god the father are persons
that is also you know like bible does
not see about it.
>> Yes it does. Yes it does. Okay. So then
why does it say in Hebrews 1:3 the son
is the image of the personhood of the
father.
>> image. Yes. How how is he the image of
the personhood of the father if the
father is not a person?
>> You see u uh I did get it. I I got it.
But you see like the image uh we cannot
uh say that uh uh god has a image.
>> Forget the image. That's not what I'm
talking about. I'm talking about the
fact that it calls the father a person.
It says he has the image of the
personhood of the father. You said the
it never says anywhere he's not he's a
person.
>> Exactly. You see, it has a very deep
roots and all that and I really love it.
Uh when you say that Jesus Christ is the
image of the living God. Yes. Uh you see
uh
>> do you agree that it says person? Do you
say do you agree that it says person,
bro?
>> No. No, I don't agree with the person.
>> We can pull up the verse. It very
clearly says personhood.
>> So when the verse says that he's the
image of his person,
>> 1:3
have the reference for sure.
>> I got you. You believe the Bible, right?
I do 100%.
>> Great.
>> Okay, good. So, we don't even have to
argue this with you. You're going to see
this and you're going to be like, "Okay,
you know what?
>> You said God the Father is a person."
>> We're going to show you. Don't worry.
You said You said it doesn't say
personhood there. We're going to show
you.
>> That's the truth.
>> And I would appreciate if the Holy
Spirit, too.
>> We'll show that later. Show that after.
>> We'll get that afterwards. Now,
>> I hope so. You find it. Yeah.
>> Hebrews 13, brother.
>> All right. Uh, first, I would like to
just keep my claims if you don't mind.
>> Wait a sec. He's about to pull it up
right now. Just wait a second.
>> Just one second, brother. I got it up
over here in the Greek of the
hypostasis.
>> Mhm.
>> Hold on. Let me pull this up here, too.
>> Would you mind uh if I just keep quickly
my beliefs before uh you uh so it'll be
easier for you to get it out?
>> It's up to you.
>> Wow. I left it up to you,
>> bro. Just go ahead, bro. Just go ahead
with what you believe and then while
logic pulls us up.
>> Sorry,
>> go ahead. You can say your beliefs while
logic pulls this up.
>> Exactly. We believe that uh
>> Exactly. It's crazy.
>> The God of the Bible is actually Jesus
Christ.
>> Nice.
>> And why is that so? Because when you see
like when Adam and Eve were in the
garden, uh they heard God.
>> I got it, bro. I got it.
>> Holy God. Okay. We got it.
>> All right. Here you go. So this does
Hebrews 1:3 says, "Who being the
brightness of his glory and the express
image of his person and upholding all
things by the word of his power when he
had himself purged our sins, sat down at
the right hand of the majesty on high."
>> Amen.
>> So you see, so Amen. So he So how is he
a person?
>> It's referring to Jesus Christ, dear.
>> No, no, no, no. Saying Jesus is the
image of who?
>> Of God.
>> Okay. So, the image of his God's person.
>> All right. See, is this uh image visible
or invisible?
>> That's besides the point. We're asking
if this is a person or not. We're trying
to figure out.
>> Does it say person? Does it Does it say
Does it say God is a person here? My my
friend.
>> Okay. Have you ever ever uh can you
imagine any person?
>> My friend, my friend, does it say God is
a person here?
>> It says Jesus Christ is the image of a
person.
>> Who is the his there? Who's the his? Of
his. Who's the his? That's God the
father,
>> right? So let's replace that his with
God. He is the image of God's person,
right?
>> But you cannot refer this person for
God. Like for example, let me tell you,
>> brother, just just if you could just
answer that, Sam, cuz you said that you
love the Bible. You said you believe the
Bible. So we this shouldn't be hard.
Does it say does it say that God is a
person here?
>> See, this is a understandings. Uh u
>> dishonest, bro. Dishonest. very
dishonest.
>> Take care of yourself, ma'am. Go ahead
and watch the clip back and see. Were I
was I honest with these two young
gentlemen.
>> After I told him that I do believe the
Bible, of course, with all my heart, did
I demonstrate that I believe the Bible?
Did my fruits show that I believe the
Bible like I said I do, or was I just
giving lip service and wasting their
time? Ask yourself that when you watch
the clip back, man. lip service is